pourquoi le harcèlement sexuel est il si
répandue et c'est difficile à évoquer
c'est tout le système qu'il faut
remettre en cause bonjour je m'appelle
jody cantor je suis journaliste
d'investigation au new york times alors
on m'a dit qu'à hollywood les actes
répréhensibles étaient innombrables
je refuse d'être cité
point final entendu
dans des articles précédents qu'est ce
que tu disais aux femmes pour les
convaincre de te parler de leur
expérience l'un des arguments c'était je
ne vais pas changer ce qui vous est
arrivé mais ensemble on peut peut-être
faire en sorte que d'autres personnes
soient protégés la vérité c'est tout
dans le détail de toutes ces histoires
ces jeunes femmes se rendaient à ce
qu'elle croyait tout être un rendez vous
professionnel
je revois encore la chambre d'hôtel que
les différentes pièces
il essayait sans arrêt de touche et je
lui ai demandé de me laisser tranquille
et au lieu de ça il les menaçait et
exigeait des faveurs sexuelles j'étais
jeune j'avais peur bonjour nous sommes
du new york times vous avez bien
travaillé pour un round stein
certains ont déjà voulu écrire cette
histoire mais à chaque fois ils
étouffent la faire parvenir des grumes
en toute allégation de pression il a
berné plus c'est un maître de la
manipulation
je vous en prie donnez moi la
possibilité de parier vous êtes sûr que
ces jeunes femmes ne cherche pas à
coucher avec un producteur pour lancer
leur carrière
s'étend au delà des ministres là on
parle d'un système qui protège les
agresseurs
qui ont reçu une compensation financière
ne peuvent pas parler elles seront
poursuivies si elles le font
et si quelqu'un pourrait parler
ouvertement des indemnisations
quelle indemnisation john
faut que vous ayez en tête que tous les
appels que vous passez sont enregistrés
dès que vous êtes suivi tu te rends
compte du nombre de harvey qui se
baladent
vous voulez que je me fasse tuer
sur regrette d'être embarqué sur ce
dossier et toi non la seule façon pour
ces femmes de faire une déclaration
officielle cet se lancer tout en même
temps
on est tous arrivé rajhi avez vous parlé
j'ai trois filles et je veux que jamais
n'accepte ni violence ni harcèlement je
vais faire une déclaration officielle
allez-y
vous avez une feu vert
ça va sortir c'est bon
les bayonnais je veux retrouver ma voix